the hill tonight for the giants we
welcome back alex wood who hasn't been
on the hill
since august 26th he had a bout with
covet now tonight he starts to rebuild
the arm again so make a start number 24
10 and 4 on the year
and that's how this game gets started
now here's ball one to the jorge soleil
on the ground into the hole crawford off
balance throw into the dirt he's done it
again
nobody does it better two down one of
the greatest arms to ever come out of
the state of california and he really
puts it on display going so hard to his
right such an awkward throw and he
throws a one hop strike to belt and they
get their man you see the bottom last
eight starts he's been fantastic in his
lifetime four for fourth a 2.48 in 13
starts against the giants bryant aboard
with two out
and morton struck him out charlie with
13 pitches his first strike out of the
game no score after one inning austin
raleigh is going to hit first then
duvall then darno
reilly on the first pitch pops this one
into shallow right field yostremski's
going to slow down and make the catch
one pitch went out and here's duval
strike three call a fastball on the
inside corner the month of september has
not been kind to dansby swanson 2-2
pitch coming up
in there strikes recalled and the inning
is over first inning that saw him strike
out one give up one base hit and be
looking to face brandon crawford
on the ground freddie freeman
saved morton some effort
there's the first ground ball out for
charlie tonight and mike yostrimski's
coming up
swing and a drive deep right center
solaire back in that triangle is there
yostremski hit it a mile but that's
where fly balls go to die yeah
kurt casalli has the catching duties
tonight
popped up
freddie freeman right next to charlie
makes the play and morton with 24
pitches has two scoreless as we go to
the third guillermo herrera the center
fielder for the atlanta braves will lead
things off there's a sharp ground ball
diving is la stella he gets up he throws
and they got him tell you what
giants brought their gloves tonight the
defense behind alex wood has been
spectacular and this time as tommy
listello who takes away a base hit
going down on his belly up quickly 0-2
pitch swing and a miss he struck him out
on another slider that's all for morton
albie's opened up the ball game of the
strikeout
he does lifted to left
wade is going to get there on the track
and make the catch hey morton has faced
seven giants he's given a one base hit
that was a single to brian
fly ball
center field heredia is there
for out number one
and that'll bring up last night's
villain donovan
solano and this one popped up to right
and two down back to the top of the
order tommy lestella
driven out deep into triples alley
solaire on the move still on the move
it's off the top of the wall and la
stella's got a double
and he can't believe that he didn't get
a homer
i mean that may be all he's got he
absolutely nuts this
now you've got chris bryant up all of
this trouble has come with two outs
runners will go the pitch
is chopped right back to charlie
and he retires chris bryant
zach michelle on the pitch now for the
giants solaire had a hit taken away by
brandon crawford in the first inning so
he's over one tonight
drilled deep center at the track to the
wall leaping try it is off the top of
the wall
yastremski backs it up
solaire's gonna stand at second
it was over the wall and he brought it
back with a flip of the leather great
play by duggar to save a run nothing
nothing to score in the fourth the
braves but the first big scoring chance
that they've had first and third
he struck him out
and he got him to chase the high
fastball up out of the zone he's not out
of it yet now travis darno
two on two out two balls two strikes
he struck him out
wow
now the giants second and third one out
punched into right field base head one
run is in crawford is being weighed and
he scores curt casalli delivers in the
clutch the first runs of the night two
nothing giants duggar is up a man aboard
and one out
and now this one skied into shallow
center heredia slides and makes a great
catch great catch
got a good jump on this with a big
outfield he had to come hard on this
ball he's kind of looped off the end of
the bat
but rosario has been [ __ ] for her
radio
struck him out
well he really followed up that back
door breaking ball with a good
two-seam movement on his fastball
albie's the lead off man coming up two
strike count
strike three caught in the outside
corner he back-doored him with that
breaking ball beauty la stella at third
bryant at second and crawford at first
so here's yaz
he blew it right on by huge strikeout
for charlie morton garcia is the new
pitcher he'll be facing freddie freeman
that was caught a double play
wow bell caught it and at first
solaire was just trying to
save his own life and couldn't get back
to the bag before
belt got there
this ball is blistered
belt spears and there you see reaction
from silverbee he's thinking this ball
is going to hit me look at he's just uh
look out it's gonna be jose alvarez
coming up for the 58th time two nothing
giants top of the seventh swing gonna
miss on three pitches
good changeup from jose alvarez
[Applause]
duggar got a good jump now he comes in
and he makes the catch this is arcia
who's going to pinch hit orlando arcia
on the ground towards the hole
crawford's got it his throat is second
they got him he got enough on the throw
to get the force played what a play i
didn't think he had a chance it's two
nothing giants tyler rogers is going to
come in to do the pitching
belt has got a shot i do believe
one out here
solaire on the ground into the hole
crawford's got a big hop takes his time
belt takes it out not a problem brandon
de brandon two down
[Applause]
hits a left
wade has got it near the fence
and that'll end the inning the rays have
their fifth hit of the game and a foot
in the door here comes darnold over two
was hit by a pitcher's first time up
on the ground to third brian's got it
that's one and a double play
and that's the ball game